the VW Beetle in all colors and
variations
German Mexican and Brazilian beetles old
and new beetles they've all come
together for the beetles sunshine tour
the world's largest beetle gathering
they rendezvous at Lubeck Airport and
form a seemingly never-ending convoy on
the roads of northern Germany it's the
tenth anniversary for this annual bug
collection a milestone that the tour's
initiator Gabriella crafts is
justifiably proud of she points out that
the beetle sunshine tour has itself
attained cult status for the
participants it's like a family reunion
they come from Italy Sweden the Czech
Republic Slovakia Poland Austria and
every year the Netherlands - beetle
drivers will find each other no matter
where they are the four hundred and
seventy colorful bugs migrate to the bug
man garden a large field right on
Covenanters baltic coast
some veterans have been on board from
the very beginning like hands yoga and
shorts he says the first time just 68
bugs assembled near the car dealership
and drove on a little tour and it grew
from there
more beetle owners showed up every year
and the gathering moved to the main
fairground in krumitz eventually that
got to be too small and it moved to tava
mandir but this year the grounds here
are barely large enough to hold all the
cars over time many of the beetle
drivers have made lots of friends at the
gatherings they get together once or
twice a year generally at the sunshine
tour that's what keeps many of them
coming back the drivers span three
generations the obsession with the cult
car has just kept going and going and
going for over 75 years but not everyone
here owns a beetle many are just here
for the spectacle zippy glitter owner of
the beetle fire engine has his own
theories about what the attraction
really is
the illusion he explains that he fights
other things besides fires he fights
boredom many of the people in attendance
here would like to own cars like these
so he's here to help put out the fires
of longing longing for a Beatle being
crazy is encouraged here the beetle
owners express themselves through their
cars this is one place where dogs aren't
allowed to scratch they have bugs beetle
owner dieter Gerda says that they had
the dogs first then bought the car and
airbrushed it to match custom jobs range
from kitsch to art this Western
rust-bucket
embodies one or maybe the other
the line between the two is fuzzy even
when it comes to accessories and tuning
Beauty is quite often in the eye of the
beholder even Santa Claus sent three of
his helpers to the gathering beetle fan
Christiana poor man had the idea the
year before but didn't go through with
it until this year when she thought she
could be a little more creative and this
was the result the get together would
hardly be complete without home bake
cookies the neon chartreuse of this
custom paint job was not available from
the factory even if many other colors
were Beatle tuner Sascha bloom explains
this had always been his dream car and
when he saw this color he liked it right
off originally the bug was blue one
winter he took it apart and painted
everything for everyday use he's got a
black beetle this one's just for show
there's no end to beetle owners
creativity
okay the variety makes for the spice of
life and the party mood all around
another sunshine tour veteran is tuner
Sydney Hoffman he shows how to get a big
sound and power out of a little car
he-man he explains that this is the
highest increment of performance
enhancement at 370 horsepower this is
the new air intake made of real carbon
fiber the diameter was enlarged to
produce more power you need fresh air to
supply the bigger turbo injection this
provides it Travie mandir is a popular
seaside resort in summer and all the
more so when the VW Beetle fans start
partying all along the boardwalks
happybirthday sunshine tour will be back
next year